Bonjour à toutes et à tous !
Aujourd'hui, un épisode un peu spécial
je vous emmène voir Jupiter.
Non, pas ce
jupiter là,  la planète Jupiter
une des planètes du système solaire les plus étudiées
et je trouve la plus fascinante.
Ce type d'image est obtenu par les
sondes spatiales comme Juno
qui orbite autour de Jupiter pour la photographier
mesurer son champ magnétique, son champ de gravité
ou encore sa température.
Mais malheureusement les conditions extrêmes
de température et de pression
empêchent d'étudier directement
l'intérieur de Jupiter.
Alors pour comprendre ce qu'il se passe
dans et sous ses gros nuages
certains chercheurs ont choisi de recréer
la planète géante en laboratoire... Easy !
Cette fois on a choisi de quitter
le confort du studio Zeste de Science
pour vous emmener voir ça à Marseille.
Voilà c'est rapide hein ? C'est fou les
transports de nos jours
Bienvenue à l'Irphé
l'institut de recherche sur le
phénomène hors équilibre
et ici il y à
un canal hydraulique
une soufflerie
et des oliviers.
Et ce qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
la mécanique des fluides en rotation
sur les planètes
Bonjour Daphné !
Bonjour Léa !
Tu as une magnifique manip !
Alors en effet, ici on a une toute
nouvelle installation expérimentale
où on a pris une grosse cuve cylindrique en plexiglas
et on l'a remplie avec 800 litres d'eau
Et en fait cette cuve
remplie d'eau va la mettre en rotation très rapide.
Donc ce qui nous intéresse c'est de décrire
les mouvements d'ensemble qu'on va observer
et de comparer tout ça avec ce qui se passe sur Jupiter
et notamment tous les
mouvements atmosphériques qu'on voit
les bandes, les vortex, sur Jupiter.
On va chercher à observer les mouvements du fluide
et cette caméra va observer
tout ce qui se passe sur un plan laser
qu'on va créer avec ce laser ici sur le côté.
Là haut c'est comme si on regardait depuis le pôle de Jupiter
les mouvements dans son atmosphère...
Exactement, c'est une vue du pôle de
Jupiter qu'on reproduit en laboratoire.
Jupiter est une planète géante et c'est  la plus géante des géantes
c'est à dire qu'elle est plus grosse et plus lourde
que toutes les autres planètes de notre système solaire réunies.
La tâche rouge, là, elle fait à peu près la taille de la Terre
et on pourrait faire rentrer plus de 1300 fois
notre planète dans le volume de Jupiter.
Mais Jupiter est une géante gazeuse
et ce que l'on voit ce n'est pas une surface solide
d'ailleurs elle n'en a peut-être pas du
tout, même sous les nuages.
Elle est constituée majoritairement
d'hydrogène qui passe progressivement
de la forme gazeuse à la forme liquide,
plus on se rapproche du centre de la planète.
Cool... et bien du coup on va faire tourner ça !
Allons-y !
Ok, donc là on est prêtes à faire la manip ?
En effet, là, tu vois qu'on a mis la table en rotation
à 40 tours par minute
Là, j'ai en direct ce que voit la caméra du dessus
et on va éteindre la lumière
pour voir ce qu'on voit dans le noir.
Donc là, ce que je fais, c'est que
j'active les pompes qui sont à la base de la cuve
et tout ça ça va mettre en mouvement  les particules
et on va les voir apparaître sur le plan laser, et donc sur la caméra.
Donc là tu contrôles le jacuzzi ?
Exactement, je vais allumer le jacuzzi !
A ce moment là, vous vous demandez
sûrement comment est ce qu'on peut voir
les mouvements de l'eau alors que c'est
un fluide transparent.
L'astuce dans la manip de l'équipe de
Daphné c'est d'ajouter dans l'eau
des petites billes réfléchissantes et
d'éclairer avec un laser.
L'eau entraîne les particules
et la caméra enregistre leurs mouvements.
D'ailleurs c'est une méthode très utilisée
en mécanique des fluides
pour suivre l'évolution des écoulements
et ça s'appelle P.I.V.
Donc là on voit des tourbillons
comment est ce qu'on peut faire l'analogie avec une planète ?
Ce qu'on modélise dans cette expérience par rapport à Jupiter
c'est vraiment une fraction de Jupiter concentrée près du pôle
et qui ne serait pas très profonde ce serait quelques milliers de kilomètres
depuis ce que l'on peut appeler
la surface de Jupiter.
Pourquoi on se permet de faire cette analogie ?
c'est vraiment parce qu'on a injecté dans notre expérience
les ingrédients fondamentaux pour comprendre
la dynamique de Jupiter, par exemple la
rotation de la planète et on a recréé
tous les systèmes de petits tourbillons,
de petites tempêtes,
qu'on peut observer dans l'atmosphère de Jupiter.
Revenons un instant sur Jupiter.
Elle tourne très rapidement sur elle-même.
Une journée sur jupiter c'est seulement 9 heures
et on appelle ça un jour jovien.
Un jour jovien un jour jovien pas.
Les bandes que vous voyez ici sont des courants de vents très violents
plus de 500 kilomètres heure, qui soufflent dans des sens opposés.
On appelle aussi ces courants des jets joviens.
Demain encore ne sortez pas vos
parapluies sous les tropiques
car les vents d'est pourront atteindre
600 kilomètres heure
alors qu'aux latitudes plus élevées
les vents d'ouest souffleront à plus de 500 kilomètres heure
comme tous les jours depuis
et bien depuis des siècles
On va pas faire ça tous les jours c'est toujours pareil !
Ce que les chercheurs essayent de comprendre grâce à leur manip
c'est quels sont les ingrédients
nécessaires à la formation des bandes de Jupiter
à quelle profondeur ces bandes descendent dans la planète
et est ce que leurs formes, leurs positions, leurs sens,
restent constants au cours du temps
Donc là, tu vois que sous l'effet de la rotation
la surface de l'eau est devenue complètement parabolique
Ca fait comme quand on touille un café en fait, ça se creuse..
Voilà ça a creusé la surface de l'eau au milieu.
Donc à petite échelle on voit des
tourbillons et à grande échelle
si on essaie de suivre globalement le fluide
on voit qu'il va dans ce sens là
alors que si on regarde plus à l'intérieur de la cuve
si tu le suis globalement, tu vois qu'il remonte
qu'il va dans l'autre sens
là, vers ici..
Une ces particules là,  elle va dans l'autre sens.
On va enregistrer ce moment là
pendant plusieurs heures dans l'idéal et
ensuite on va analyser toutes ces  données
pour voir quels sont les mouvements préférentiels suivis par les particules
et voir si on arrive à reconstituer la formation de bandes
et puis on peut même analyser à temps court tous les phénomènes
qui conduisent à la formation ses bandes là.
Alors, concrètement on fait comment pour traiter ces données ?
eh bien on part des images de la caméra
qui filme le dessus de la cuve
et ces images permettent d'obtenir
le déplacement des particules
et donc la vitesse du fluide qui les entraîne.
En faisant la moyenne de tous ces
déplacements
on arrive à une image comme celle ci
et Daphné va nous en dire plus
On a représenté ici le sens de
l'écoulement :
en rouge on a représenté le fluide lorsqu'ils se déplace
dans le même sens que la rotation de la table
et en bleu lorsqu'il se déplace dans un
sens opposé à la rotation de la table
et donc tu peux voir ici qu'on a une
formation de bandes qui est donc analogue
à ce qu'on observe sur Jupiter
quand on la regarde vue du pôle.
D'accord. Et là au milieu  ?
Et donc au milieu on a une simulation numérique de la manip
qui a été effectuée par Benjamin.
Donc ça c'est une image qui vient d'une simulation numérique
donc dans les mêmes
conditions que l'expérience pour voir
comment le fluide se structure et on voit
bien qu'on reproduit
la structure en bandes de l'expérience.
Du coup, là, c'est quelque chose qui est en 3d c'est ça ?
C'est une coupe à travers un domaine qui est 3d
donc là on voit ici, vu du dessus le cylindre qu'on a coupé en deux
donc si on se déplace à l'intérieur de la manip
on voit bien la structure tridimensionnelle de l'écoulement
on voit bien que les jets qu'on voit en surface
pénètrent  très profondément à l'intérieur de la cuve
Du coup c'est quoi l'intérêt d'avoir une
modélisation et une expérience ?
C'est toujours assez complémentaire
puisque dans l'expérience on est limités dans les quantités d'informations qu'on peut extraire
on a vu le plan laser, donc on a
juste de l'information au niveau du plan laser
la simulation on a une information
complètement 3d de tout le système
ça nous permet de vérifier, de comparer ce qui se passe dans la manip et dans la simulation
pour la question de la longévité, de  la stabilité des jets
qui est ce qui nous intéresse nous sur Jupiter
le numérique n'est pas très adapté
on peut juste faire quelques dizaines voire centaines
de temps de rotation mais c'est tout
alors que la manip va la faire tourner pendant des heures
ce qui correspond à un très
très grand nombre de temps de rotation sur Jupiter.
Pourquoi c'est intéressant
d'étudier la longévité de ces bandes ?
La longévité de ces bandes, on l'observe depuis des centaines d'années
c'est quelque chose qui est
très surprenant parce qu'on s'attendrait
à ce que les jets évoluent dynamiquement
changent au cours du temps alors que ça fait 400 ans qu'on les observe
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas bien compris.
Et c'est quoi du coup le futur pour cette manip ?
Alors pour cette manip là, à terne, on aimerait
bien suivre au fur et à mesure
tous les résultats que va nous amener la mission Juno
est donc maintenant on a un super outil
pour essayer d'étudier tous les phénomènes qu'on observe sur Jupiter
par exemple des vortex qui ont été observés aux pôle de Jupiter récemment
on pourrait essayer de les reproduire dans notre manip.
Ok, merci beaucoup merci de m'avoir accueilli dans ce labo
avec cette magnifique expérience
Voilà,  j'espère que vous avez aimé ce nouveau format
nous, ça nous a bien plu de travailler dessus
donc donnez nous votre avis
faites nous des retours et
puis dites nous si vous en voulez plus
Ephéméride :
demain la journée ne durera que neuf heures
et nous fêterons les Joviane.
Bonne fête à toutes les Joviane.
Ne nous mettez pas un vent
abonnez vous, nom de Zeus !